you may have heard there's been one of
the biggest diamond robberies in history
millions of dollars worth of diamonds
have been stolen from a hotel in Monte
Carlo and the reason that people like
diamonds is because they sparkle so much
here I've got a model of a diamond and
the diamonds that you see and the
diamonds that are stolen are cut with
these very precise geometrical faces
which is what makes them Sparkle and
they sparkle so much much better than
this lump of glass because Damond has a
very high refractive index it bends
light very strongly and although people
don't realize it they really value
Damond
because of its refractive index but
chemists think about diamond in a
completely different way they're
interested in Damond because of its
structure you can see here I've got a
model of diamonds it's very strong I can
push hard on here and it will not
distort at all so if you look at this
atom here it is bonded to four other
atoms one here one there third one here
and fourth one here and each atom is
bonded to four others so you get very
strong structure chemists value diamond
because it's so strong and there are two
different ways you can use it to be
strong one way is as a window to let
light in or out of a high-pressure
vessel so here is a diamond window which
is mounted on the plate and the whole
thing fixed to a metal fitting for high
pressure work and if you look through
the diamond you can actually see I can
see Brady's wedding ring can't remember
whether it's platinum I think palladium
yeah so I can just about see his lens
now the idea of this is that you can
shine light through a very high-pressure
fluid and look at
reaction the high pressures not terribly
high perhaps a hundred atmospheres 200
atmospheres pressure but if you use
glass you'd have to use really thick
glass and that would distort the
experiment the diamonds that are now
used for Windows like that are usually
synthetic diamonds though the structure
is just the same but the real power of
diamonds is when you need very high
pressures and you do this with a diamond
that is tapered like this one you can
see it goes downwards down here and when
you have a shape like that if you press
hard on the top because the area of the
top is much bigger than the area of the
bottom you increase the force as you
push down and multiply so you give very
high pressure at the bottom with Windows
shape like this you can get a very high
pressure on this tiny face at the bottom
which has a special name it's called the
cullet face of a diamond so you can take
a pair of dams like this one on the top
and another one pushing up here and push
them together and this little cell here
has two plates one here and one here
which are pushed together and push the
Diamonds together and the force comes
from screws that hold the plate together
so if I turn this over you can see there
are three screws which you can tighten
which force these together the amazing
thing with this tiny cell you can
squeeze a suitably small sample to
pressures of more than a hundred
thousand atmospheres this is really high
pressures so the way you use the cell is
that you take say small crystal that you
want to submit to a high pressure and
put it between the Diamonds surrounded
by a small ring made of tungsten so the
liquid will transmit the force from the
Diamonds onto the crystal because if you
just put the crystal between it it will
be crushed to be
but it's surrounded by liquid the
pressure pushes from all sides and all
being well you just get squeezed some
crystals it makes no difference if you
submit them up to pressure but if you
have quite a complicated molecule as you
increase the pressure it can change its
structure even the diamonds that are
used in labs are quite valuable and so
sometimes even our diamonds get stolen
but the thieves are usually disappointed
because their value on the black market
is very small because nobody wants to
wear diamonds like this as jewellery
originally diamonds were made by heating
carbonate very very high pressure and
this was expensive and you got rather
poor diamonds modern diamonds are made
by so-called chemical vapor deposition
where you take the clamp pound in the
gas phase at high temperature and it
decomposes to give a layer of carbon and
if you do it in the right conditions you
can build up diamond literally layer by
layer so if you want you can coat metals
with diamonds or you can grow whole
crystals of diamonds rather like the
ones here is there a difference between
manufactured diamonds and diamonds that
come out of the ground manufacture
diamonds do not usually have the same
high optical quality that makes natural
diamonds so beautiful because natural
diamonds have been made under high
pressure and sat under the ground for
millions of years and the tiny
imperfections which don't really matter
to scientists have essentially
disappeared because the diamond has been
heated so long that they can diffuse out
and so you get these really perfect
crystals so I don't think that the high
market
jewelry industry is yet being threatened
by synthetic diamonds